en medio de un mar de polémica alexéi
navalni se enfrentó a la justicia rusa
por supuesto fraude y blanqueo el
opositor ha asegurado que todo es un
montaje del kremlin pero de que se le
acusa en 2014 la justicia concluyó que
navalny y su hermano robaron 580 mil
dólares de dos empresas para después
blanquear 300.000 dólares en empresas
ficticias algo que en ese entonces el
crítico negó y abrió no frost a el juez
blind o simplemente emitió un veredicto
sobre las acusaciones fabricadas en
moscú por el comité de investigación que
tenía una clara motivación política que
mucho watts aunque se le condenó a tres
años y medio de prisión su condena quedó
en suspenso y en 2017 el tribunal
europeo de derechos humanos calificó la
sentencia de arbitraria pero rusia no
revisó el caso y obligó a navalny a
cumplir la libertad condicional hasta el
30 de diciembre de 2020 sin embargo en
agosto de ese año el opositor fue
envenenado con novillos y entró en coma
tras acusar al kremlin de intentar
asesinar lo realizó su recuperación en
alemania y no pudo presentarse ante las
autoridades el 28 de diciembre de 2020
el servicio penitenciario ruso
denunció que no cumplió su libertad
condicional y un día después se ordenó
su búsqueda y captura algo que no se
produjo hasta el 17 de enero día en que
naval ni regreso a rusia he visto un
montón de tonterías en la justicia
parece que el abuelo en el búnker tiene
miedo de todo porque simplemente
rompieron y tiraron el código de
procedimiento penal lo que está
sucediendo aquí es simplemente imposible
esto es la máxima anarquía whiskies
shipping blues rock winner naval ni
denuncia que no pudo presentarse ante
las autoridades durante esos meses
porque estaba en coma pero a pesar de
ello la justicia rusa rechazó su recurso
el pasado 28 de enero